from NBC News state government buildings
face bomb threats for second consecutive
day buildings across Mississippi and
Arkansas received bomb threats on
Thursday one day after similar threats
for state capital complexes across the
US to evacuate so uh yesterday it was
eight states nine nine states yeah all
Republicans over what all Republicans
it's a mix and it's not all like swing
so what's going on do you tell Santa
clir oh well okay so as you guys know
this is one of my favorite stories right
now so yesterday the Capitol Buildings
in I'm gonna read from my list
Connecticut Georgia Kentucky Mississippi
Montana Maine Minnesota and oh Michigan
Hawai and Hawaii all received bomb
threats they were all evacuated most of
them were in the morning based on local
time main was like afternoon uh some of
them were in session having come back
from the winter holiday some of them
weren't so they all uh had these sweeps
the majority of the ones that I could
track down the the law enforcements that
were releasing information said there
were hoaxes were receive V email email
typically it seemed like it went to
someone who worked at the state
government building and it triggered an
evacuation today there are other
government buildings in multiple States
so like Mississippi has several not the
state capital but other Affiliated
government buildings that are receiving
similar threats the interesting one from
yesterday was that Maine had received I
think it was 60 schools in Maine mid
December had received bomb threats via
email so this is something that's going
on uh you know it's not exactly the same
thing but it's very much like a swatting
for these government buildings in some
cases and you're asking about patterns
so some are Republican states some are
are Democrats some are in session some
are not in session it's not really that
there's a consistent pattern from what I
can see but it is interesting that now
it's spreading throughout other St
states that were already affected are
seeing other and you're
saying I mean they're bomb threats so
they're not sending in the SWAT team
necessarily but they are disrup business
remember when Target faced a bunch of
these these threats I wonder if this is
related I wonder if whoever did in the
casinos right casinos it reminds me of
the when the casinos had am I wrong I
remember remembering the story they
received some like not bomb threat but
it was like you know we've hijacked all
your data please pay us and no that's
way different that theel my only point
is it's interesting because it's all
cyber crime like no none of the
buildings that were affected yesterday
and as far as I know I haven't done all
of my due diligence research on the
buildings that were affected today none
of them actually had explosives in them
so you're saying this is a cyber crime
because they just found out like Russia
has been hijacking our cyber security
for the past 13 months this these were
emails that were sent that's what I'm
trying to see what she say all of it is
done online it doesn't know there's no
clear indication it's not like four
people walked into buildings you
know email it theoretically could all be
one person or it's a coordinated cyber
Le attack I mean you just don't know and
some of it is I think it's foreign
testing the response from these capitals
I think it's foreign I think it's an act
of War uh I I should say that's the that
seems the most probable outcome because
it is it is crippling our our ability to
govern it's shutting down our
institutions we have the weakest cyber
security system we have out there we
pretend we do we have the strongest we
have the weakest the fact that they can
hijack the Congress website they did it
like last year in two seconds and they
the reality is there's there's no
defense no one has any defense anywhere
in the world defense is hard offense is
super easy when it comes to cyber
warfare there's uh it just there's no
way to defend a system it's just not
possible there are certain things you
can do but man I love how all of these
uh you know every business will have
their cyber security policy you know
when I worked at Vice they have this
they're like everybody just do not click
links in your emails and the next day
it's like oh we got TW you know 12 more
people clicked the links we got fished
again passwords got it's oh non-stop no
matter how many times you tell the
person not to do something they'll do it
anyway and then they'll lie about it and
say they didn't do it oh like or they'll
like click on the email for the Nigerian
prince because they think they're going
to be a billionaire you know what the
the the mo the most basic way people
breach systems is back in the day it
used to be that the quote unquote hacker
would drop a floppy disc in front of a
bank mhm and then what happens is
someone will pick it up walk inside
stick it in the computer and go what's
this computer infected then it became
CDs then it became USBS and USBS are are
the commonplace thing now someone will
just they'll put a virus on a USB
they'll walk in front of the building
Target building and they'll just drop it
and they all all they got to do is wait
cuz sooner or later someone walking into
that that building for their job will
see the USB and pick it up and stick it
right in their computer on the network
and infect the network and no matter
what you do no matter how many times you
tell these people they don't care
because that guy who works in the mail
room goes I know we're not supposed to
but what do I care clicks it in and goes
oh crap it was a virus wasn't me and
throw a stick away nothing you can do
about it nothing so these kind of
vulnerabilities we face look if if they
can shut down state capitals and what
are we what are we dealing with like 13
states in two days how many states is
this it's definitely nine stat capitals
today some of them are happening in the
same place so let's say there if there
are two I only saw two new affected
states that would be like 10 or 11 but
still evacuating our state capital
buildings
inhibiting our ability to convene and
govern imagine if they do that and they
will when an actual attack happens right
and then all of a sudden our uh uh
centers of Power are unable to
coordinate and figure out what's going
on I get asked this all the time people
are like how could a civil war really
happen oh my it's just so insane how how
how easy it is to break a machine I can
give you a million different scenarios
but imagine what would happen if there
was a terror attack and then at the same
time the foreign adversary who did it
shuts down Communications in the United
States
what happens when multiple law
enforcement agencies show up to the same
scene unable to communicate how many
stories have there been where police
show up on scene and shoot the wrong guy
MH in New York they open fire on a
perpetrator and they hit a bunch of
innocent people on accident it is chaos
and if they can't coordinate communicate
and there's an explosion in DC and then
one jurisdiction says we we we've lost
Communications we got to figure out
what's going on and there's there's no
way to communicate effectively then a
bunch of random people show up and no
one knows who anybody is yeah now I I do
think the the our security apparat in
the United States has plans for things
like this I'm just saying you bring this
on the federal level not the state but
I'm talking about DC you bring this to
the to the border of Texas and then it's
chaos for the feds respond there's an
attack The Border's in chaos people are
running and screaming uh state law
enforcement shows up you got some plane
closed guys nobody knows who's who
there's a story going viral that just
dropped about uh Trump that that Trump
supporter who got arrested by the feds
what's what's his name actually I don't
know if it pulled up it was the guy who
that Trump group in Georgia or whatever
and two plane closed guys branish a
firearm at him and he runs and then he
tries to flee from him it turns out they
were FBI agents and everyone's saying
they they did it in this way because
they wanted him to get shot and killed
to fight back not realizing they were
law enforcement plane Clos FBI show up
to an attack with guns drawn state law
enforcement doesn't know who these guys
are they show up and they say drop your
guns and they're all screaming at each
other you ever see that video of the ATF
guy getting detained by the cops every
libertarian loves this video it's the
meme it's the one that got turned into
the meme he walked to the guy's house
because the guy reportedly bought a
shotgun and he's like you know give me
give me your information banging on the
door the guy who lives there calls the
police there's a strange man with a gun
is banging on my door the cops you up
and they're like on the ground now and
he goes no I'm I'm law enforcement
they're like shut your mouth on the
ground no and the and the ATF guy is
like no I don't have to and then they
throw him down he's screaming oh I can't
breathe I can't breathe don't they have
like a cold word for each other or I
just watched Soo much Blue Bloods no I
don't know I'm just saying watch the
video they throw this ATF the him's
screaming he can't bre they don't care
they don't care now this was one ATF guy
and a handful of cops so it gets
resolved afterwards but imagine if this
is federal law enforcement subverting
the law on the border Texas state level
trying to enforce the law on the border
an attack happens Communications go down
it's serious man it's like that mean it
say like uh cops arrest undercover cops
for drug buy that happens all the time
all the time is it is it it has happened
on several occasions been documented
your tax dollars at work FBI is setting
up a fake drug sell and then the DEA is
doing a fake drug buy and then they all
turn out to be like oh oh we're all law
enforcement you the taxpayer paid for
all of it you got to ask yourself why
why is this happening this
week I mean I think it's start of the
New Year what's your theory I'm just
saying like it's just try to like ploy
to show how like the capitals are just
being I think I think this Saturday
something happens maybe I mean one of
the things I found interesting about
this is not like they picked the swing
States and then no no they picked a
bunch of State houses of various sizes
not all of our most populated states
across the country and not all of them
were in session and so in some ways to
me this is all just testing right this
is to see what the response is that's
why I made the comparison to the casinos
right to a certain level like when you
do that kind of thing and especially if
you do it to two major different Casino
Brands you're ultimately trying to see
which one will give you money and which
one won't you want to know what their
response is they want you want to know
what their security protocol is uh and
you know effectively obviously in this
case no one's hurt everything's fine but
on the other hand there is now an
obvious way to get you know state
capitals to close down as fast as
possible well think about like it's like
an election period and somebody just
calls in or does something like this at
like a voting at like some place where
people vote yeah at a polling center
right so there's a lot of ways where you
can just merely disrupt something at a
time when there's a finite amount of not
to to throw too much shade on him but
you know if Jamal Jamal Bowman could
just pull the fire alarm this is
effectively what anyone could do to stop
a vote that they don't like in one of
the states um I can't remember which one
have my head uh there the their Supreme
Court the state supreme court was in
session so theoretically if you didn't
want business to take place you don't
even need to be in this country to be
able to say I don't I'm going to disrupt
the day thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim c.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time